says she was repeatedly struck in the
legs with an axe when she was detained
in a concentration camp run by british
colonialists
it was in the 1950s her husband was one
of the leaders of a rebel movement
frustrated by colonial land grabbing its
fighters wanted kenya to have
independence from british rule
they never apologized neither did we get
compensation we just came home and
suffered in poverty i spent so much time
in detention and our children suffered
throughout
researchers say british colonial
authorities detained hundreds of
thousands of people both fighters known
as mao mao and suspected sympathisers
and killed tens of thousands of them one
of the camps was right here it's now
part of a school the teachers say
this building was where new prisoners
were held before being taken in here for
interrogations
castration and rape were used to extract
confessions in intelligence as well as
beatings so severe they were often fatal
the crackdown since came to be known as
one of the worst atrocities of the
british empire as the guns sounded a
salute
an empire of which queen elizabeth
became the figurehead when she was
crowned in 1952
she was visiting kenya a british colony
at the time when her father died and she
became queen
the mao mao rebellion and the brutal
crackdown began shortly after
the british government didn't
acknowledge the atrocities for more than
half a century until nine years ago when
it compensated a group of about five
thousand torture victims the one who was
asking
was among the lawyers representing them
in court in london he says the
settlement was a step forward but about
200 000 more victims or their surviving
descendants were left destitute and
deserve compensation for abuses the
passing away of her majesty the queen
presents
a wonderful opportunity for the kenya
government to come out even as they
congratulate the new king
come out
and request the british government to
place their part
in bringing an honorable closure to this
matter
wasn't among the group who were
compensated and says she can't afford a
lawyer
neither is she among those on social
media expressing anger at britain's
monarchy or former empire following the
queen's death
but she says it's still not too late for
the british government to say sorry and
make amends
malcolm webb al jazeera muyga kenya